you know on average it takes several
years to make this diagnosis and most
people from when symptoms first present
and what happens is one of the proteins
in the neurons becomes dysfunctional and
it accumulates and it kills the neuron
in parts of the brain called The frontal
and the temporal region and the symptoms
progress about one in eight cases are
genetic and this is a progressive
Disorder so his function will get worse
and worse and he won't be able to do
many of the activities we all do in life
it's about 20 percent of dementia second
only to Alzheimer's so it's not uncommon
now we had said earlier in the graphic
50 to 60 000 cases a year but it's
probably higher because it's under
diagnosed